[Music]
welcome the fat man beyond I'm Kevin
Smith
normally I do this with mark barnard n'
avengers without mark barnard and man
they gave me a ticket
you know me plus a guest and I took my
kid it was real Sophie's Choice Jason
Mewes was crying about it mark barnard a
little upset Ralph Garman didn't say
anything but I'm sure inside seething
full of hatred but I tipped my kid
because I took my kids see Iron Man back
in the day finished the Marvel Saga the
infinity saga if you will together by
going to see Avengers : endgame
last night at the premiere so that's
what we're gonna talk about this is not
a review I'm not qualified to give
reviews and stuff you know everyone
always says you [ __ ] lose everything
it's not true you don't hear about the
things I don't like see how that works
you'll hear about the things I like all
the live long day and I like a lot of
things man some people like he's not
[ __ ] picky or choosy obviously not
have you seen my [ __ ] movies when it
comes to other people's movies I'm even
less picky and [ __ ] choose that's
when I resort to being a fan long before
I was a filmmaker I was a film fan loved
movies and stuff so any movie that can
make me feel like I felt long before I
picked up a camera myself and became a
filmmaker tried that's that's worth it
to me that's great filmmaking man films
movies are supposed to their escapism
take you someplace journey to a wild
place you never could before with some
trace elements of humanity and story
that we could understand but like take
me somewhere wonderful that's what the
movies are about those Marvel movies do
that as well I [ __ ] suck their dicks
so hard they're [ __ ] good man they're
great in most cases and they're little
like time machines for somebody like me
I'm [ __ ] 48 man so the good times are
behind me and all that lies ahead is
[ __ ] death and the Red Skull floating
around going who wants a stole and
killed someone so like I you know I look
for something that makes me feel young
at heart that makes me feel happy that
gives me that same [ __ ] feeling I had
when I sat next to my father and watched
Raiders of the Lost Ark and he would be
like
love this movie because it reminds me of
the movies that I used to see when I was
a kid the cliffhangers meant
that's a germ that's passed on
generation generation oh man loved the
movies he passed that on to me passed it
on to my kid as well so as I sit there
with my kid watching these movies I'm
like I love these movies because they
remind me of the movies I saw when I was
a kid
Star Wars movies and stuff and she's
like they still make those Star Wars
movies I'm ago you're right but those
that's where I fell in love with those
those kinds of big movies and I never
thought one day I'll make a movie and
[ __ ] I was happy to be an audience
member and stuff then an indie film
happened and suddenly I got to play but
we're not talking about that we're
talking about Avengers endgame [ __ ] this
is a movie this is so much [ __ ] movie
ain't never been a movie like this
before man I don't give a [ __ ] what
anybody says in terms of like a build-up
to a final conclusion I've said this
about other movies before this one is
about the absolute closest you get to a
live-action comic book this movie felt
like an annual like a giant-sized annual
or a big multi-part crossover standalone
event bookshelf format or Baxter format
from back in the day
prestige format man it was just epic if
they had a high bar to clear not only
they clear the bar by a couple thousand
miles high they stuck the landing in the
most impressive superhero landing of all
[ __ ] time we're gonna get into it I'm
going to tell you about it this ain't a
review this is a I mean I'm just gonna
tell you the story as I remember it
that's how I do my [ __ ] I don't review
I'm not like what the filmmakers were
going for it [ __ ] that I don't know what
the filmmakers going for other than they
wanted me to be enthralled [ __ ]
shocked happy sad they wanted me to
laugh they wanted me to cry and they
[ __ ] did it they did all that in the
span of three hours over and over and
over again man you know what I've been a
director of 25 years I'm just coming
around to this thinking it might be a
two-person job
you know the Russo brothers thrust it
took two [ __ ] guys to make a movie
this [ __ ] big a movie so big it had
two directors and man they did a
phenomenal [ __ ] job they cut their
teeth in the world of television like
you know arrested
and then gave us some of the greatest
motion picture epics of all time that's
not just hype kids it's not just me like
oh you [ __ ] blows everything marvel
that'll that'll stand up in a [ __ ]
court of law man you ain't seen anything
like and there ain't anything ever been
anything like Avengers endgame man it's
crazy let's get into it before we do
spoilers
big time [ __ ] spoilers man I'm not
doing this to ruin the movie for you so
if you ain't seen the movie yet [ __ ] off
you know you're not supposed to say that
you know to your audience but I'm
telling you I am gonna go deep what I
recall of this movie and it's gonna be
spoiler full this ain't spoiler free
nothing but me talking about the [ __ ]
that I want to [ __ ] like blow and
[ __ ] so get out while the getting's good
and come back after you've seen it
yourself and whatnot all wait a [ __ ]
I can't wait you leave put it on pause
or whatever the [ __ ] because some people
who have seen already we want to talk
about it so here we go before I go
further little housecleaning
me and Ralph Garman coming over to to
Ireland and in England and Scotland to
do Hollywood babble-on tickets at cease
mod.com that's coming up man May 9th
we're gonna be over there May 9th I
think to the 16th or something like that
so come hang out with me and Ralph's
gonna be making jokes having a great
[ __ ] time man tickets at zis Montcalm
okay here we go
vengers endgame I went to the premiere
full disclosure
as a guest of Chris Hemsworth so
naturally you know take this review of
the grain of salt but you were gonna get
the same review whether Thor brought me
or whether Hawkeye brought me or whether
nobody brought me and I just paid my two
bits to see in the theater
Avengers endgame what a weird place to
open a movie right half the world's been
snapped two heroes and [ __ ] lost kind
of like in an empire strikes back see
kind of place but they did not return
this Jedi holy [ __ ] they went far above
and beyond that although in the end
credits there is another star movie
that's kind of getting not knotted too
but like here in the end credits when
they do the core 6 members of The
Avengers they have
their signatures as well so you know
it's Chris Evans it's gotten America but
then you see Chris Evans signature and I
remember they did that in the last Star
Trek movie that the old cast was going
to be in they'll sign their names and
their names went off into the stars so
you know Kevin Feige who is the [ __ ]
brilliant genius behind all this and
deserves all the [ __ ] credit for a
10-year vision 22 [ __ ] films of like
no this could be cool we could build up
to [ __ ] vanos man and like this
gigantic [ __ ] off movie or every one of
our [ __ ] characters all the IP came
in together and whatnot just the same
way you do in a comic when you were
reading like you know an annual or
something like that or when they do the
big crossover event annually
hence annual so our movie opens in a
world where everyone half of everyone's
[ __ ] dead and it happens I guess
based on Tony's lost in space with
nebula and he's mentions in the amount
of days again I was it was a lot to take
in so much movie and that's not
complained it's amazing I can't wait to
see it again
so I can like break it down and ingest
it this was just pure enjoyment for
mendin so if I remember correctly Tony
and nebula lost in space based you know
following the events of infinity war and
he said how long he was out there and
how shits running out we heard in the
trailer right where he's just like you
know [ __ ] them when I go to sleep I'm
gonna be thinking you when he's
recording a video for Pepper Potts into
his helmet so meanwhile back on earth
you know the Avengers and everybody else
kind of dealing with the fact that like
he did it oh my god it is unbelievable
and so Tony lost up in space and then
you know he's going down for the count
and then Olson there's a bright light
and you know you're like who is and how
do you not know who it is is Captain
[ __ ] Marvel who just showed up like a
couple months ago so Captain Marvel
spoilers and again all spoilers rescues
Tony Stark and nebula brings their ship
single-handedly back to earth I guess
that's after the events and Captain
Marvel's PostScript they you know showed
her going where his fury so I guess what
had happened was
she talked to them they were like first
go get Tony Stark so she goes off to
space rescues Tony Stark brings him to
earth Tony Stark shitty and pissed like
[ __ ] not having it like mad at Captain
America like he'd called them a traitor
or something like that was real [ __ ]
had a mean on it was pretty harsh and
you know wants nothing to do with these
fools meanwhile cap Marvel is just like
[ __ ] it let's go kill thanos you know
and the Avengers like oh it's that
simple and she's like yeah we'll find
him we'll [ __ ] kill him or we'll make
him pay and they're like you know hey
man he's got the stones let's just get
the stones and do what he did unsnap
everybody and stuff and then all of a
sudden you know somebody's like here's a
signature heat signature when he used
the stones the first time is
unbelievable release of energy that
happened it's happened again you know on
this world the signal energy signature
from this world so they know where to
[ __ ] find him and also nebula knows
were funny because nebula said like he
always talked about when his work was
done he would go to the garden so
they're gonna go to the [ __ ] planet
where we saw thinnest at the end of
infinity war and [ __ ] confront him
what I forgot to say was the opening of
the movie Hawkeye
train and his daughter had a fire bow
and arrow how to pull back and bang and
he goes pull the air and she's good shot
he goes pull the arrow out and his
[ __ ] he's on a family picnic in his
backyard family that we met in in
Avengers 2
age of Ultron and then boom they turned
to dust and he's left by himself and
[ __ ] so that's like kind of the cold
opening in the movie before like the
[ __ ] Marvel card and [ __ ] so the
heroes are like [ __ ] it man we know
where he is let's go to space and
everybody jumps into rocket ship rocket
the raccoon and off they go
except Hawkeye he's not with them we'll
find him later on he went nuts
as one would so he became Ronin
[ __ ] so they all go up to
[ __ ] space spice to confront Thanos
on his planet they do the jumps just
like the didn't guardians they get to
the planet Thanos is all [ __ ] up it's
all burned and [ __ ] like that
his arms all scarred and and wither
like from burnt the arm that had the
glove on it the Infinity Gauntlet and so
they go further they buy like all of a
sudden he's sitting there and bam
[ __ ] Captain Marvel comes shooting in
and just [ __ ] knocks him on his ass
everything you want in the first I don't
know 10 minutes of the movie 15 minutes
the movie they go to [ __ ] kill Thanos
and Thanos reveals that he used the
stones to destroy the stones so the
stones don't exist anymore so they can't
unsnap so [ __ ] you I did that so that
nobody can undo what needed to be done
and you know I think it's nebulas
talking to him at one point and he
starts talking back to her he's like see
daughter you know you bubble and then at
[ __ ] nowhere swap [ __ ] Thor cuts
Thanos head off right there first
15-20 minutes in the movie and you're
like what the [ __ ] are we gonna do for
the rest of the movie man they killed
Thanos already and it was so [ __ ]
satisfying I screamed out loud a lot
throughout this movie people sat in
front of me kept turning around looking
at me it was mostly a cast and crew
screening all the Avengers were in
attendance and [ __ ] it was kind of
surreal but I spent most of my time
literally on the edge of my seat and
screaming when things happened and
knowing yes it yeah over and over again
that's what this movie will do to you
bring tissues mags you're gonna spill a
lot of bodily fluids not just like tears
lots of Tears but also like I can't
believe they do that I'll tell you what
those moments are man again this is a
spoilery review so danos [ __ ] killed
by thor right then and there man and the
whole world is [ __ ] hopeless because
there's no Infinity stones and that's it
that's your opening of the movie and
then they cut to five years later so
we've lived for five years in the Marvel
Universe with all the people half the
people being gone world being weird and
stuff cap running a like a survivor
group like kind of a PTSD group that he
we saw him in in Captain America Civil
War and the Russo brothers I released
one of them's in that scene it's pretty
cool so
you know cap talking about the things
here in the trailer about people moving
on and they find it hard to move on so
you start seeing life after the snap and
the Avengers are still together as a
team and still fighting missions one
thing you keep hearing about it's like
somebody slaughtering whole gang
communities and whatnot and you know you
start piecing together you're like
that's the Ronan son
that's Hawkeye all these movies
everyone's been going like Hawkeye what
a jerk Hawkeye [ __ ] and they turn
them into you know two [ __ ] Man of
Steel in this movie they give him they
redeem Hawkeye everybody gets a moment
in this movie some get more moments than
others but everybody gets to play this
is incredible storytelling
incredible fanservice perhaps the best
fanservice ever [ __ ] provided and
stuff and still all holds together as an
entertainment that if you've never seen
any of the other movies you would still
enjoy the [ __ ] out of this still works
there's lots of references to stuff that
happened before but they're not enough
where you're like what well I mean
number one I know all the movies but
even didn't know the movies they kind of
explained [ __ ] along the way so you know
time has gone by and nothing is improved
and people are sad and they miss their
loved ones and in a storage facility I
guess in San Francisco there's a big van
that we recognize from ant-man and the
wasp and a rat there's a little like a
convenient I'm sure mark barnard know I
have something to say about I was
totally okay with it rat runs across the
controls that snaps on the controls
which turns on the quantum tunnel and
booms Scott Lang comes out of the
quantum realm like into the storage
facility he gets out and he starts
looking at the world around him and it's
completely different and he goes home
and this is like some really touching
[ __ ] heartbreaking [ __ ] there's a lot
of moments that's moving to make you cry
he knocks on the door and his daughter
answers and he's been gone for five
years so the little girl that we met in
ant-man and ant-man the wasp is now like
a 17 year old teenager and you know Paul
Rudd never ages anyway so he shows that
the door looking the exact same even
though it's five years in the future
really poignant and [ __ ] bittersweet
man like [ __ ] he's like what happened
he has no idea so he apparently gets
filled in and then he shows that member
in the trailer they're like hey man it's
me Scott like ant-man we met in Europe
he shows up at Avengers mansion when you
know people are the Avengers have kind
of fallen into this yeah we protect the
world what's left of it and [ __ ]
doldrums and you know but there's been
no avenging of the snap or anything like
that
like that's it they've just kind of
what's to do the talisman thrown in so
Scott Lang shows up at Avengers man at
the The Avengers facility upstate New
York and starts telling Captain America
and the Black Widow like I was in the
quantum realm and you know it's a place
he explains it like real [ __ ] go small
and he's like and then you know I got
out and bam it's just five years later
and he's like but that's just it he's
like to me it was like a day or
something like that time moves
differently in the quantum realm so he's
like maybe that's the key to all this so
right away everything we'd heard about
in the rumor mill is like I think this
one's gonna be about time travel they go
all the [ __ ] in on time travel and it's
a delight they referenced their
cinematic forbearers a lot of Back to
the Future jokes and stuff like that but
the idea is what if we could use the
quantum realm what if we could go back
in time somehow to the moments before
the stone like what if we stole the
stones before Thanos ever could so that
he could have never collected them so it
becomes a time heist movie and they
literally say that in the movie couple
thousand times time nice it's a time
heist so they break the you know
meanwhile at the same time Tony
the Avengers go see him and with Scott
Lang and he's like I'm out of this like
if you came to talk about avenging
because he's got a daughter Morgan him
and Pepper Potts have a kid he lives and
like this house up in the country and
[ __ ] in the woods by a lake and he's
living just his normal life having a kid
and he's just you know he the snap was
devastating but like he lived pepper
lived and they got a kid so [ __ ] wasn't
that bad for him like yeah they lost
friends but then of course like after
the Avengers come visit he sees the
picture of Peter Parker and like it eats
at him that he lost the kid remember cuz
he didn't want to bring a kid into this
and stuff so that's knowing at the back
of his head caps like come back and he's
like no way if you came for that you you
know if you if you know if you want to
stay for dinner
no business we can just chitchat and
[ __ ] but like I'm out of this but
meanwhile Tony has been working on time
travel and in a really cute scene he
just comes upstairs to like talk to
pepper he's like well I did it she's
like good but he's like I figured out
time travel you know and she's like what
and so the idea is like do we do
something about it and you know she's
gone like look everything worked out for
us and there's a chance that if you go
back you know maybe that that doesn't
happen Tony says that as well but like
that's what a hero does so they set the
table really well because they're like
Tony Stark never has to go into that
world again and he'll be happy until the
day he dies he's got this adorable
little daughter Morgan who he [ __ ]
loves he's with pepper like you know the
Snap is a distant memory and stuff he's
he's happy he's content that's not what
a hero's allowed to be so the Avengers
come see him you could see his wheels
turning and whatnot and that's when he
tells pepper and then there's being a
moment of like well you got to do what
you got to do kind of thing speech so he
goes back to the Avengers facility they
all gather meanwhile we've gone to see
Hulk and Hulk is like Hulk from the
comics in the 90s when Peter David made
him the smart Hulk so he looks like the
Hulk but he thinks and speaks like Bruce
Banner so that was real great for like
an 80's 90's comic comics kid to like
see smart Hulk up there like you know oh
my god then it's cool because you could
see it's more Ruffolo than it's ever
been before and he's talking it's not
just like Hulk smash and he was like
look I was always fighting the Hulk like
he was some sort of virus I had to get
out of me but what if he was just this
is what I was meant to be he was the
evolution so he's constantly in in Hulk
form at this point except one scene in
the movie during the the journey when
they cap breaks everybody up into teams
you're gonna go here
go here you're gonna go here because
they got to chase the Infinity stones
down in time and most of that time is
the time that we've spent seeing the
Marvel Universe movie so it's this
double joy of we're like oh my god
they're doing their greatest tits man
they're doing a victory lap and it's not
even like we're jumping to moments in
time that you never saw they're gonna
jump into moments that we know and we
weird moments to like obviously moments
from the first Avengers movie but then
moments from like Thor the dark world
like this movie goes out of its way to
be like [ __ ] you you're gonna watch Thor
2 again like they're gonna make you do
it man so many plot elements about
endgame are tied directly into the one
Thor movie that everyone's like me so I
don't know it kind of redeems that movie
in many ways not like it was a bad movie
but it makes you go like oh [ __ ] I
better revisit Thor dark world and
that's what I'm gonna do tonight so it's
working so they you know they're
starting to pull the team together they
got the Hulk
they got Tony comes back they got nebula
on their side and rocket and they've got
cap Oh Thor Thor is probably the
ballsiest decision they made in the
movie because Thor Thor got thick with
two seas so what happened is after the
events like they showed you know at one
point when Captain Marvel came to earth
and rescued Tony there's a shot of Thor
like sitting there real angry in the
[ __ ] trailer and [ __ ] you know she's
like she says what's with them and
they're like he's [ __ ] he's kind of
PTSD man he [ __ ] killed like he
should have went for the [ __ ] head he
we could have killed Thanos but he
didn't and all this should happen so
he's [ __ ] Superman and [ __ ] so then
we saw Thor kill thanos in the first
like 15 20 minutes so then when we come
back to Thor he's living with Korg and
new Asgard so we see Valkyrie and all
the rest of surviving as Guardians have
moved to this town called new Asgard
where Thor is kind of like the both or
is the king
and so it's like this fishing village
like a few word if you will and Thor
spends most of his time drinking beer
and playing fortnight with with Korg and
meek from from Thor Ragnarok so Tiger
watch HEDIS in the movie and he was
great and I saw him on a red carpet I
want to give him up but he's doing an
interview I don't even know him but I
just want to hug him because I love Thor
Ragnarok so Thor gets like heavy like he
went to pot he doesn't look like god of
thunder anymore
he you know he looks like he looks like
me with my [ __ ] show up and heavier
than me and [ __ ] like a strongman gone
to seed and they keep him that way the
whole [ __ ] movie its glorious like
this is it for the Avengers and that his
last go-around
he's literally heavyset and schlubby the
only thing like weirder they could have
done if they turned him into a [ __ ]
frog like at one point they you know did
in the comics or something like that or
you know beta ray bill replaced him it
was it's crazy and and like it works it
absolutely works man and because the
whole movie services every Marvel movie
ever all the 22 and that services
through a Ragnarok like you know they've
kind of went in a lighter direction and
so they kept leaning into that direction
with Thor who like in in one of the
ballsiest moves in end game stays fat
the whole [ __ ] movie it's crazy even
like when it comes to the final standard
[ __ ] like that
and they make it work for him he's
suffering from PTSD he's [ __ ] like
doesn't want to go out doesn't want to
do anything but [ __ ] a drink and [ __ ]
like that so they have to drag him back
into the into the fight you know when
they're like we have a chance to fix
this we can go back and if we get the
stones we can unsnap we can bring them
all [ __ ] back and stuff so he's
suffering from PTSD and not the Thor we
kind of remembered and whatnot he looks
more like the dude he's dressed like
Lebowski the whole movie he's got like
[ __ ] it's two layers
you know just sweatpants Thor it's
pretty genius and Chris Hemsworth is and
I'm not just saying this because the guy
invited me the premiere and he's in Jay
and Silent Bob reboot what up he's legit
[ __ ] hysterical in the
we doing this and he brings real
poignancy to it as well
because as each team drops through the
time hole and goes streaming through the
quantum realm into these very specific
moments in Marvel history you know
things happen things go wrong things go
right and stuff like that so they've got
to do [ __ ] like okay you know the stone
was in New York two stones were you know
in New York around this time and it's
the time of of Avengers so the you know
tez Iraq they've got to get and they've
got to steal it from themselves so you
get to see what happened in Avengers
after they caught Loki wear Loki's like
I think I'll take that drink now
so they lead you down the tower they
brought in Robert Redford's character
you know from civil war was it yes
Pierce Franklin Pierce and and they
brought in Joe Grillo you know who
played crossbones so you know who played
Ludlow run low like in this in because
we're jumping through time so our heroes
have the benefit of knowing like what
happens in the marble universe so you
know when they jump back at one point to
the post-arrest of loki like love love
rumlow is in there in the elevator like
cap winds up back in an elevator
surrounded by a bunch of tough guys who
all have the staff you know Loki's
scepter and so caps job is to steal the
staff cuz that's got the tesseract
that's got the stone in it and stuff so
he gets into the elevator and you're
like oh [ __ ] man it's gonna be a repeat
of the Captain America Winter Soldier
scene where he [ __ ] everybody up in the
elevator and you know you're like that's
awesome because the Russo brothers and
they made that movie as well and then he
don't fight anybody in the elevator even
though he's sitting them there and he's
like run low and he knows that like in
the future like he knows everyone in
this elevator is a [ __ ] Hydra agent
because he's lived through the movies
but where they jump in the movies nobody
knows this yet except the people who are
Hydra agents so in a really bit of
clever writing there's not a [ __ ] ton of
fighting in this movie it's not a fighty
fighty movie although by the end [ __ ]
yeah
but like a lot of things are more clever
and [ __ ] like that so cap gets out the
elevator he simply goes like you know
they want me to take this and they're
like I don't know cap we had very
specific orders and then he goes I have
it now and then he goes
hail Hydra so Captain America saying
hail Hydra and they all go everyone in
the elevator reacts like holy [ __ ] he's
one of us too and he just walks out with
the scepter
they have fanservice moments like that
paying off setups from like three five
movies back and [ __ ] one from the they
pay off or a callback from the first
Iron Man movie man that's the
penultimate moment in this [ __ ] flick
so caps mission at one point is like
like like they get the tesseract but the
tesseract gets away because like Ant Man
Tony Stark from the present an ant-man
er teamed up and he flicks ant-man onto
Tony Stark from the end of Avengers he
goes in when Tony's got the you know the
heart thing and pulls the plug and stuff
so Tony has a fake heart attack and
whatnot so they can try to steal the
tesseract away but then Loki steals the
tesseract and [ __ ] off so then you're
like what they like we got to go back
further in [ __ ] time in order to do
this [ __ ] so they do another jump and at
one point Tony Stark like they got to
jump back in time because they only have
a certain amount of Pym particles I'm
sorry I like I only saw it once so I'm
trying to remember and [ __ ] I'm a STONER
they only have a certain amount of Pym
particles to make the jumps so they're
like maybe if we jump back in time to
when Hank Pym invented the Pym particle
we can get more so we don't have that
we're not worried about like one last
jump and [ __ ] so they jump back to
shield in the 70s and you know at one
point Captain America sees Peggy Carter
like in in an office from the other side
of a window and [ __ ] like that he walks
he tries to hide in office and there's a
picture of him behind him on the desk
and he looks at the door and says
Margaret Carter and [ __ ] and then he
sees her outside and he's like longing
it's really beautiful [ __ ] like that but
he can't spoil it he can't [ __ ] ruin
this mission you know obviously nobody's
allowed to be in touch with their former
selves or their past selves and [ __ ]
meanwhile Tony runs into his dad
in a really [ __ ] touching scene they
bring back John Slattery who's played
Howard Stark you know in in Iron Man 2
and in Civil War and so Howard and Tony
see each other shield and like Tony
winds up hanging out with his dad for a
few minutes and it's it's really sweet
they don't go smallsy
you know where Tony's just like always
loved your dad and he's crying or
anything like that he's talking to his
dad and his dad is bringing home flowers
to his wife because he just found out
I'm gonna [ __ ] cry this movie is so
amazing he has found out that she's
pregnant and it's pregnant with Tony so
he's talking to his dad on the day that
his dad's gonna go home and celebrate
with his wife that they're about to have
this baby
so Tony Stark the old Tony Stark our
Tony Stark is able to talk to his dad
and talk about being a father himself
which he is now and he says like you
know like I used to think that my old
man was hard on me and now I just
realized he was just always looking out
for he's like now that I'm a dad I just
get it and that's as close to like a big
like sprawling crescendo cue and tears
in that moment I love that they kept it
real it is so true to Tony Stark's
character that he wouldn't be like I
love you dad and [ __ ] but they do let
him [ __ ] hug Howard and it's
hysterical cuz out of nowhere this guy
who's just walking with him to his car
says thank you it gives him this big hug
and he goes thank you and that's how it
looks in when he goes for your service
to this country and [ __ ] like that and
he's like oh all right and then
something really mind-bending happens
and the movies full of [ __ ] like this
it's just fanservice wonderful
fanservice Markus and McFeely the
[ __ ] screenwriters I don't know if
they deserve the credit they deserve to
so much credit but I don't know who came
up at this moment but it's really nice
Howard Stark gets in the car goes to get
in the car and his driver opens the door
and he goes Thank You Jarvis and you see
[ __ ] Jarvis and you realize that's why
Tony built the AI Butler I mean those of
us who know the comics knew that you
know Jarvis was the butler a vengeance
Avengers mansion but in the world of the
movies like it just started off in the
first Iron Man with Jarvis being the
house
ai and then it moved into the suit ai
and then Jarvis became vision eventually
and then vision gets killed and never
comes back like you know a lot of folks
come back in this movie some don't
envisions [ __ ] one of them that was
really disturbing so in any way you've
seen now the entire life of this
character and then you see the reason
why the origin Tony like we always felt
of course he called this AI Jarvis
because Jarvis was the name of the
Butler in Avengers mansion but they in
the movie universe they do this one
thing they just go one better by being
like that's who he grew up with there
was a Jarvis Jarvis was his driver and
his Butler so when young Tony grew up
and built an AI there's a whole story
behind the story that they don't even
[ __ ] tell would you just fill in the
blanks and you're like one day Jarvis
died and [ __ ] when Tony built the AI
he decided to name it after like one of
his only friends in life above the life
like it's just [ __ ] fantastic
fanservice meanwhile Thor has to go pull
the ether from Thor dark world from Jane
Foster Natalie Portman who's been out of
these movies for a red-hot minute and
was like I ain't doing these movies
again they got her to come back
everybody comes back she comes back so
we see her so Thor's got to go to Asgard
which is still you know when he jumps
back in time there it is everybody's
around including his mom Freya who dies
that day in the movie in Thor the dark
world so Thor jumps through time and
sees his mom he jumps through with
rocket and he sees Frey and he doesn't
want to confront her and ship and then
he's skulking around the palace and at
one point she confronts him and he's
like and you know again like Chris gets
to like be funny in the movie as like
fat schlubby Thor and so you know she's
like you're my son but you're not my son
from this time are you music how did you
know that and for a play it's even
better I can't even do it he was just
like he breaks down to crying he's like
I'm gonna buy me like but she's like I
was raised by witches you don't think I
could [ __ ] tell a little fanservice
[ __ ] like that so he has this
conversation with his mom
who he knows is gonna die by the end of
that day and you know he's Thor's
[ __ ] depressed he's like I don't
think I'm [ __ ] worthy like look at me
and like I [ __ ] up and I should have
gone for that and like he's just kind of
broken and so she gives him the pep talk
and the kind of like you are the best
and blah blah blah
really beautiful seem to be mother and
son two characters they afford these
like moments with their parents Tony
Stark with his dad and Thor with his mom
and you know kind of charges them up as
they head back into the adventure so
most of the adventure is predicated on
we gotta get these stones before Thanos
does in the timestream but in the
timestream nebula jumps back to with who
war machine to the beginnings of Garba
giving of guardians of the galaxy that
planet were star-lord where it opens and
he's dancing and he goes and finds the
orb with the stone in it at the end of
the movie it find out has an infinity
stone it so they bring you to the
beginning of gardens the galaxy and
Chris Pratt redoes his dance sequence
until he gets knocked the [ __ ] out and
[ __ ] but nebula is there and meanwhile
by being in the same era as her other
self like they're accessing the same
memory so at one point Thanos has old
nebula strung up you know and he's kind
of pulling her apart after a fight she
had with Gamora and so she had and all
the sudden she starts projecting a
conversation from her head projecting
literally that our nebula had like the
nebula who's come around you know has
been become a hero
and suddenly Thanos knows that these
heroes who he doesn't even know the
Avengers at this point really he knows
that they're coming again he has just
started his hunt for the stones and so
suddenly he's like it works I get all
the stones and these [ __ ] are trying
to jump back in time and stop me from
doing that so all we have to do rather
than go hunting
these stones is wait for them to find
the [ __ ] stones and take him back and
I'm gonna do that and [ __ ] cuz that's
always been his dream right he's got a
hard-on for the snap he wants to snap it
in happening so suddenly he's on their
asses
you know like [ __ ] Thanos is a player
again like a not just in flashback
suddenly the flashback or the
time-travel Thanos becomes the main
baddie Thanos that they gotta fight for
the rest of the [ __ ] movie
remembering that they killed Thanos in
the first [ __ ] 10-15 minutes of the
[ __ ] movie so suddenly you got old
Thanos who we never really met except in
like you know credits sequence of
Avengers when you're sitting on his
throne and [ __ ] like that that's the one
that they wind up fighting in the third
act try and think again so so Black
Widow and she hunts down Clint who has
become Ronin and he's in Japan just
[ __ ] icing Yakuza people and [ __ ]
like that just killing [ __ ] because
he's lost his entire families lost his
mind so she brings him back into the
fold
him and her he's the first one to test
the time tunnel the time is bracelet
that Tony Stark developed he jumps back
in time to his farmhouse and he sees his
family sees his kids and stuff and then
he gets yanked back and stuff so he's
like it works we got a chance we could
[ __ ] do this man so boom they all
[ __ ] head out now
those two wind up going to is a four
mirror know you know wherever the
[ __ ] soul stone was where Thanos had
to pitch gomorrah you know off the cliff
in order to get the soul stone you have
to give up something you love where the
red skulls hanging out and [ __ ] so they
show up and the red skulls there and you
know you give them the same rap about
you must move something you love so one
of them in order to walk with the soul
stone before you know anybody can come
get for Thanos could come get it one of
them has to [ __ ] die one of them has
to give up the other and both of them
are trying to give up their lives for
each other don't even longtime friends
like at one point is a beautiful
callback line when they're like in the
[ __ ] ship traveling through space and
[ __ ] and he turns to her and he's just
like there's a long way from Budapest
and it reminds you of the Avenger
I'm where you know she's like this is
like this is exactly like Budapest he's
like you and I remember Budapest very
differently so beautiful fanservice
moments like that so they want to go to
bat for each other like and you know
Barton is Hawkeye he's just like I got
nothing to live for and I killed a bunch
of [ __ ] people so let me do this you
know and [ __ ] she's like no like I
never had anything in my life and this
family gave me everything and so like
she's like I'm gonna do it for my family
you know and they're heroes so both of
them are like they start beating the
[ __ ] out of each other not like fighting
but knocking each other down to be like
I'm doing it I'm doing then they both
[ __ ] go over the cliff but you know
he's attached to a [ __ ] cord and [ __ ]
and she's like let me go you have to let
me go and [ __ ] like she can't hold
her and she goes black widow [ __ ]
sacrifices herself for the soul stone
and that's it that that's it like she
don't [ __ ] come back it's not like it
then the third act there she it dead
just like Gomorrah Gomorrah stays dead
but Gomorrah is in this because they've
went back in time and so that Gomorrah
who's still like working for her dad
thanos sees this video here's these
things knows that it happens or like the
snap eventually happens she's like we
can't let him do this and she teams up
with the old with the new nebula because
old nebula knocks out new nebula and
takes her place and hides amongst the
Avengers and like destroys the [ __ ]
time tunnel thing they created by
bringing Thanos through it so she brings
Thanos from the past into Earth's
present the post snap world you know
time travel so there's a lot to follow
so meanwhile real nebula convinces old
Gamora that hey man we got to stop this
[ __ ] like in the future we become
[ __ ] friends we become sisters and
[ __ ] like that and so old Gamora helps
new nebula you know one point she runs
into Peter quill and Peter's
just like Gomorrah and he touches her
and [ __ ] and then she [ __ ] like decks
and takes a mash kick your [ __ ] hands
off me bringing their relationship back
to the very beginning like so it's not
like a reset but like oh here we go
again
so what the Russo brothers are doing
masterfully and I'm probably not I'm
probably forgetting [ __ ] is set the
table to get everyone where they [ __ ]
need to be man
and this time heist is they all go off
to get the stones Hulk
Bruce Banner goes to dr. strange because
they said at one point there's and one
more keystroke ah there you go hey
everybody Jaime's here you were watching
this Mittal's
Mittal Kent Smith Kevin Smith but now
you're watching Jay Mewes and I hacked
into his little business here because he
didn't bring me to the Avengers right
he went with him and his daughter or
what about the hetero life mate Muse so
this is what you get Smith if you only
had a VPN you'd be saved my friend I use
Express VPN for multiple reasons one
being I travel all over the place I'm
here in London in Australia but I use it
because I want to watch my shows that I
watch weekly in the US of A but I can't
do it on Netflix and Hulu and all that
when I'm out of state at a country but I
can with my VPN that's right expressvpn
gets me where I need to be on my Netflix
Oh what up Sofia the first huh look how
easy it is expressvpn less than seven
dollars a month how do you like those
apples hey you want to get three months
free click the description box or put in
expressvpn com /sm OD s-- mod mod I want
to say one more time it is $7 a month
with a 30-day money-back guarantee man
oh now back to Thanos Smith the big
Avengers watcher you know what back to
him because I'm gonna go do my own thing
I'm gonna go watch my own
with expressvpn there's two stones in
New York one of course was the tesseract
from Avengers and one is the time stone
because it's held by Doctor Strange and
Doctor Strange is still surgeon at this
point he hasn't become dr. strange he's
dr. Steven strange not dr. strange
master of the mystic arts so Hulk goes
to Greenwich Village - you know - to the
sanctum sanctorum and the ancient one is
there you know from from Doctor Strange
so it's not dr. strange he's got to deal
with the ancient one and she at one
point does that poo that you know astral
punch which knocks him into the astral
plane so Bruce Banner gets knocked out
of Hulk's body so you get to see Ruffalo
playing Bruce Banner even though it's a
mostly Hulk as smart Hulk movie so the
smart hope goes down and Bruce banners
in a spectral astral form if you will
trying to convince her to give up the
time stone she's like you're out of your
mind and that were the ancient one I
know meant to be sexless so eventually
you know he goes Stephen strange gave
the stone up and she was like strange
gave up the stone she's gone all right
strange is meant to be the best of us
and again he hasn't happened yet but
she's the ancient one so she knows so
she's like if he gave away the stone it
must be there must be a bigger plan so
she opens up the eye of agamotto and
gives hope that stone so I think that
covers all the stones right the
tesseract the the time stone the soul
stone the stone from the space stone I
believe it is from guardians the ether
from for dark world that's five how many
stones are there six or five five think
if there's a six I forget what that one
was but I think I've covered everybody
Exodus is like five knuckles and then
there's one right there - right where's
like you know so anyway my man has come
into the [ __ ] present like bad
fan OHS and he comes to like the
Avengers may after a ship goes up to the
comes through the time device they just
start raining fire on the Avengers a
facility and just level it to the
[ __ ] ground just destroy it trying to
kill everybody because they're like
these [ __ ] if they succeed and what
they're doing I will never get those
[ __ ] stones let's kill them all and
we'll just take the stones and go
because they've now collected the stones
and they put them you know onto they've
got a an Iron Man type glove and they
want somebody to [ __ ] wield it
somebody got to do it so Hulk's got the
glove on at one point and [ __ ] does
the snap with it and they're like what
happened like you know and they open up
shutters and they see birds outside and
then you know because they're all locked
in the facility this is before it gets
blown up and then there's a ringing
phone and Hawkeye looks at it and it's
his wife Linda Cardellini played his
wife she's uh Velma from you know I mean
she's been a lot of things but she was
Velma and Scooby Doo she's calling him
so you're like holy [ __ ] maybe they're
back but you don't get to celebrate his
boom
Thanos starts raining [ __ ] fire on
the Avengers mansion and she on the
Avengers facility he opens up time holes
well first he has big last showdown
[ __ ] you know everyone's gathered and
whatnot and Steve and Tony and and Thor
like come together to face down Thanos
this this old fan house in the present
who now knows what they're [ __ ] up to
and [ __ ] like that so this is a notice
in his prime they're even fighting
weakened Thanos that's whose head they
cut off in the beginning in the movie
this is [ __ ] mad Titan Thanos and his
goddamn prime wielding a weapon that
looks like a helicopter [ __ ] blade and
[ __ ] so they have a kick-ass [ __ ]
fight scene with these three heroes
taking on Thanos and Thanos is in prime
form if you came for the whiz-bang and
the punchi punchi they they don't
[ __ ] skimp on it at all it's
fantastic and the avengers are getting
their [ __ ] ass beat oh i forgot
there's a wonderful moment in on Asgard
with Thor
we're before he gets out of there like
he you know at one point he [ __ ] like
throws out his [ __ ] hand and his mom
is there and she's like sometimes it
takes a minute and then [ __ ] mule in
the air shows up in his [ __ ] hand
because he's back in the past so Mounier
hasn't been destroyed yet by hella and
when he gets the hammer like Hemsworth
is such a good actor even through all
like the heavy ass makeup
he's so elated he's like I'm worthy like
after all this time he's like oh my god
I [ __ ] still earn the hammer so then
he [ __ ] calls down the lightning and
they suit him up but he's still fat Thor
like I kept waiting for him to be like
well as soon as the lightning hits
they're gonna thin this guy up it's it's
Thor's outfit is just [ __ ] big man
very big so cap Iron Man Thor go to
confront Thanos and have this wicked ass
[ __ ] fight and [ __ ] like that and
Fano says just beat my ass and [ __ ] and
then at one point you know [ __ ] Thor
gets knocked on his ass and drops Mullen
here because he's fighting with Mullen
ear and Stormbreaker and [ __ ] and all of
a sudden like [ __ ] you know he's
about to fan I was about to like [ __ ]
kill always trying to drive the [ __ ]
Stormbreaker
into Thor's chest and head cut his head
off like just like he was like you
should have gone for the [ __ ] head so
he's about to kill Thor and all of a
sudden BAM he's [ __ ] it with
something and when you're in the
audience you're like no no cuz Thor's on
the ground who - [ __ ] possibly how
who hits Thanos hard enough that he's
gonna [ __ ] be moved let alone knocked
off a [ __ ] Thor and what could it be
is it Mullen here and it is Mullen here
and you know like but if Thor's on the
ground who could be [ __ ] wielding
Mullen here and they [ __ ] cut to
Captain America with his hand out
[ __ ] and the hammer comes back into
it he's wielding Mullen you remember the
moment and like a age of Ultron where he
bunt to move it and it moved just a
little bit and Thor looked and was like
Jesus Christ maybe he's worthy
they cut the door and he's like I knew
it you know because it's like Captain
America of anybody like Thor this is a
[ __ ] that breaks me up is worthy enough
to wield that [ __ ] hammer because
he's so [ __ ] pure good of heart so
cap fights the [ __ ] out I gets his door
his [ __ ] shield broken by by a fan
stano's beats his ass into the [ __ ]
ground [ __ ] nut shot you see from the
trailer where he pulls the [ __ ]
shield like at one point Tony goes hey
man I made your new shield so it gets a
shield back everybody gets the [ __ ] back
no linear comes back homeboy gets a
shield back and stuff like that Tony got
the armor back on but you never really
left the armor behind so they all
[ __ ] fight caps using his [ __ ]
millionnaire and shield combo to beat
the [ __ ] out of Thanos banging it and
[ __ ] like but buying cap Marvel who I
left off like she comes in in the first
15 20 minutes to help go kill thanos and
[ __ ] but then she's like I got [ __ ] to
do on other planets then when they come
back to her later on she's cut her hair
so she looks like the short-haired Carol
Danvers which rocket makes a joke about
and stuff but then she returns for this
for the [ __ ] you know fan o ship
comes through the [ __ ] sky and [ __ ]
like that and rains fire on Avengers
facility and then he fights
Thanos fights like you know our [ __ ]
three heroes and beats all their asses
and then he opens up [ __ ] wormholes
you know in dimensional holes we're
[ __ ] like millions and millions of
[ __ ] minions and beasts and monsters
and uglies come to earth and he's like
you know normally I don't [ __ ] take
any of this [ __ ] personally but I'm
gonna enjoy burning this little stupid
[ __ ] planet to a cinder like he's
just now I'm gonna wreck shop [ __ ] you
people like and he's got the army to do
it and it's literally Captain America
only because everyone else is down for
the [ __ ] count this Captain America
versus Thanos and his entire [ __ ]
army and cap is gonna be beat and we've
been told that this is it for cap and
he's gonna die in this movie in [ __ ] and
so you're like here it is he's got the
broken shield [ __ ] pulls it tight on
his hand he's still ready to [ __ ] go
and then all sudden you hear a voice man
you hear you know cap do you read me and
it's [ __ ] Falcon he goes on your left
which is [ __ ] you know Civil War [ __ ]
out I know you're not supposed to cry
about this [ __ ] Mean Girls take your
video and [ __ ] say
unfuckable you are and stuff like that
I'm giving [ __ ] like my wife tells me
I'm unfuckable so I don't need a
stranger to tell me that number one
number two
I'll pay anybody make me feel something
in this life and these [ __ ] movies
make me feel and when [ __ ] I heard
Falcon go like on your left I just
wanted to kiss the Russo brothers that
is [ __ ] top-notch fanservice right
there they know we've been listening and
listening [ __ ] closely man so that's
a moment right out of Captain America
Winter Soldier right does a Civil War
Winter Soldier work where he's like
where he meets Falcon he's like on your
left and he keeps running by his cap
looks over his shoulder and [ __ ]
Falcon Falcon a hole opens up and black
panther and Sheree and Ocoee come
through the [ __ ] rift represent
Wakanda and then [ __ ] Falcon comes
with them and then through this hole the
other returning Marvel heroes hey it's
the Guardians the galaxy through this
whole holy [ __ ] it's [ __ ] spider-man
like every [ __ ] Marvel hero returns
and stands behind Captain America and
[ __ ] takes on phantoms it is
mind-bending like it's [ __ ] crazy see
it on the biggest screen you possibly
can because you ain't never seen
anything like it
you know when remember the opening and
the challenge of the Super Friends when
they ran at each other and [ __ ] we saw
that in Civil War Russo brothers gave us
that it's like wow that's a piece of my
childhood come to life this is like a
Gustave doré a woodcut it's so [ __ ]
beautiful
and everybody fights everybody everybody
gets a [ __ ] moment in this movie it's
[ __ ] absolute batshit crazy yeah they
all [ __ ] fight meanwhile there's
trying to [ __ ] get the Infinity
Gauntlet the new gauntlet that's got the
gems in it and [ __ ] Thanos gets his
hand in it but [ __ ] boom cap Marvel
shows up and beats the [ __ ] out of him
stops him from doing the snap and stuff
and [ __ ] she's gone but then he does
this [ __ ] trick where she's got she's
been in his fingers back it looks like
she's gonna break his fingers off and
I'm in the theater going back
[ __ ] I loved it when they cut his
head off I was it yeah they get to kill
him twice in this [ __ ] movie spoilers
so in any event she about to break his
[ __ ] fingers off and then he does
something he like pops the glove so one
of the stones pops out into his hand and
then he [ __ ] uses that to like punch
her in the face and she goes flying
across the [ __ ] screen and [ __ ] so it
looks like he's gonna fight like Captain
Marvel's the best of the best and he's
about she just [ __ ] got iced by Thanos
too and so you know he [ __ ] gets the
gauntlet you know in the middle of this
vast battle and [ __ ] everybody's
fight and it's everyone you love it's
all your [ __ ] heroes and it looks
like a comic book [ __ ] come to life
looks like a gigantic you know [ __ ]
who let me see who'd be the best artist
man I mean I don't know I don't want it
like I'm trying to figure like cuz I I
don't want to do it injustice and
somebody be like what like my first
instinct was to be like you know when
they did hanna-barbera
Super Friends character studies the
great like Steve Rude used to do a lot
of those character designs sometimes
they just put all those heroes and one
[ __ ] frame you're like wow man it was
it was kind of like that or it was like
you know reading [ __ ] Secret Wars and
seeing every [ __ ] character and one
double pay a splash page double page
spread is it's mind-bending it is
excellent
cinematic entertainment this is
something you can't do on a Broadway
show you know or anything like that this
is only something you could possibly see
in a movie you know or in a movie that
streams on your [ __ ] device or
whatever the [ __ ] it's just so crazy the
top / out and out there now fare credit
it all came from comics so you could see
it in comics as well this is the first
time you see it like writ large on the
big [ __ ] screen it is mind-bending so
eventually Thanos gets himself to
[ __ ] infinite Infinity Gauntlet onto
his hand and [ __ ] like that he [ __ ]
beats Tony Stark like Tony's got at Iron
Man fighting all he [ __ ] can everyone
[ __ ] fights
forgets a suit and she fights because
remember she fought an Iron Man 3 so she
knows how to [ __ ] fight like every
[ __ ] hero gets to fight come back and
[ __ ] fight it's beautiful it's nuts
and [ __ ] but Thanos and Ironman go to it
toe-to-toe and then fan oohs beats the
[ __ ] out of Ironman takes the glove and
he's like puts it on he's like don't you
[ __ ] people understand paraphrasing
like I am an evitable and he [ __ ]
snaps his finger and you just hear the
snap the empty snap and then he turns
the [ __ ] glove around then Gauntlet
around and the stones are gone and
[ __ ] you cut to Tony and the stones
are in the [ __ ] Iron Man glove and
just fixing into place and so Stannis
goes I am inevitable and then Tony goes
I am Iron Man and he [ __ ] snaps and
like oh my god this just destroyed them
all basically he reversed the snap like
they reversed the way I understand the
movie is I think hope reversed the snap
because at one point later on he's like
my truck is there's a long day Numa he
says like I tried so hard to bring nat
back with a snap he tried to bring bring
BlackWidow back but she didn't come back
with everybody else so Hulk snap brings
everybody back and that happens like
before Tony snapped
Tony snap defeats Thanos and his army
all of a sudden they just cuz you're
like how the [ __ ] do you get out of this
like they've painted themselves into a
corner this is like [ __ ] World War 3
and of course they could paint
themselves out of the corner simply by
letting them snap so you see all of the
[ __ ] minions dust off and start
turning into dust and everyone's a guy
haha going apeshit and whatnot and
[ __ ] then you see fan OHS who is a
great character man Josh Brolin deserves
like all the credit in the world and the
brilliant part is who turned him into
[ __ ] Thanos but that performance
which takes an actor and a team of
digital experts and [ __ ] is fantastic
you forget that's not a real [ __ ]
person that's a big ass cartoon man and
still there's such humanity and pathos
even in his leg defeat like as much as I
wanted to see him [ __ ] lose when he
sits down and like he knows he's about
to dust they don't let him speak
they don't give him a speech or anything
like that he just looks [ __ ] defeated
and it's the young fan OHS and again we
get to see him kill thanos twice in this
movie that's how good this movie is they
knew you wanted to see Thanos too high
so they're like we're gonna do in the
first act we're gonna do it again in the
third act and you're gonna love it just
as much both times so boom evil is
vanquished and [ __ ] like that
life doesn't like go back to absolute
normal it has five years of past so Ant
Man you know wasp comes back hope Van
Dyne and stuff we see Hank Pym we see
Janet Van Dyne everybody [ __ ] comes
back they they're hanging out with his
kid at the end and the kid is 17 now
like she it's not like hey she's a
[ __ ] kid again like she wasn't
ant-man the wasp so I don't know what
that means man if that means like if you
do another ant-man movies it's set in
the future we're two kids seventeen in a
post snap world or do you do a tail
pre-snap but who would want to watch
that it'll be a while before they can
get into the pre-snap stuff and they
could always use that but I don't know
how they'll touch time-travel again
because they've done it so well in this
movie man you know they adhere to the
rules that we know from other movies but
at the same time they introduce new
rules with like know if you change
something in the past the future does
not go back to normal it [ __ ]
everything up so like we have to be
delicate about this so after danos is
vanquished then we got a day tomorrow we
got to see where everybody goes and you
know everybody turns to look at Tony and
Tony is [ __ ] fried the snap killed
him just like the snap you know fried
[ __ ] Thanos and [ __ ] fried off half
of his face Tony is the same [ __ ] way
and he's just like catatonic and not not
really my death store and so the kid
spider-man is like we did it mr. stark
we did it we beat him and he's like
Tony's just not there
Pepper moves the kid and she's like we
did it like you did it Tony it's over
it's over and he never says anything
again he just closed his eyes [ __ ]
dies Tony start guys of the movie sons
of [ __ ] man but he gave his [ __ ]
life what a hero he wanted to stay home
and raise his kid that's what he earned
that's what he deserved he got that for
five [ __ ] years after the snap but in
order to give everyone else their
[ __ ] lives back and their families
back and stuff he went for it [ __ ]
he was Iron Man but not hard enough to
[ __ ] live so he dies right there and
then there's a funeral where every
Marvel character attends all the people
we know and love from these [ __ ]
movies as Tony is laid to rest and
there's a really beautiful scene with
Favreau who you know fabs directed Iron
Men started this whole [ __ ] ride him
and Kevin Feige you know had this dream
of like imagine if we got to like the
Avengers and they got so much further so
there's a scene with fabs and the little
girl who plays Morgan you know and he's
like how you doing at the post funeral
it's real sweet it's like something out
of terms of endearment and you know
she's all like I'm good I want a
cheeseburger and he smiles and instantly
he like oh like I know what that is
[ __ ] Iron Man want a cheeseburger
what he [ __ ] got out of captivity
when he first got home he's like I
wanted cheeseburger and so fabs goes
your dad he like cheeseburgers too and
it's so [ __ ] like we're that little
kid in the movie like that's it we've
lost Tony star Guinness so nice to hear
something so comforting and he goes that
is so cute he's like knew all the
cheeseburgers you want oh my god I love
it so much that's what you say to a
[ __ ] kid anyway let alone say it to a
kid who's lost your father who's like
the most incredible human being world's
ever known the guy who saved everybody
so sweets in those there's movies and
perhaps supermen and superwomen and [ __ ]
like that but it's the men and women
part of the equation super is what gets
us in you know look at the whiz-bang but
it's the men and women part of the
equation that makes us [ __ ] stay you
want to be these people not because
they've got superpowers because they
they're human beings just like us who
make the right choices make the hard
choices and [ __ ] like that
really beautiful touching [ __ ] so
they're not even done bring again bring
a towel bring a beach [ __ ] talax you
will cry throughout this entire [ __ ]
movie man cap well here the Thor decides
to leave he doesn't want to be king of
new Asgard and he turns that over to
Valkyrie and she's like I'd like to make
some changes around here
I bet you will and he joins the
guardians the galaxy and he says he's
like look at us together as get together
again as guardians of the galaxy is like
what so if that's how they're gonna do
it Thor might continue on you know cuz
they can still make these [ __ ] with
horror movies or he could be part of the
guardians or whatever the [ __ ] but he's
going off like into the universe to find
himself he's leaving Earth but not in a
shitty I hate Earth kind of way just
like you know he goes look for so my
whole life I've been trying to be this
person that I'm supposed to be now I
just want to be Who I am like some
really beautiful [ __ ] man they give him
a great storyline and it's crazy ballsy
that they just stuck him in a fat suit
that whole [ __ ] movie anybody coming
to see the rip Thor this is gonna have
to deal with the performance instead and
it's really quite beautiful
so that's Thor's storyline Black Widow
as we know lost her for the soulstone
Clint gets to go home and be with his
family let's see
Tony's laid to rest Captain America you
know now this was that we all expect cap
to die all the trailers make us feel
like he's gonna [ __ ] die fighting thin
I was gonna die for this country at one
point like you know they talk about Tony
looks at it's Tony and ant-man together
Tony Stark and ant-man and they're in
the past that the Avengers and they're
looking at Chris Evans uniform from the
Avengers and so Tony Stark goes like Oh
cap those pants did nothing for your ass
and like ant man's like I always thought
of your asses America's ask cap one
point Captain America has to fight
Captain America from the Avengers so our
Captain America fights that Captain
America from the Avengers and you know
they're expertly [ __ ] matched and so
really dazzling sequences catfights cap
ones wearing the mask ones dodge but
eventually it takes him out and that cap
is like down for the count
and Chris Evans looks at them because
he's asked ass up face down and he goes
that is America's ass like [ __ ] like
that was fantastic there's like a
fortnight joke when we first meet Thor
him and Corrigan Meeker playing for at
night and he gets on like a headpiece
and argues with the kid
fortnight and [ __ ] Ralph like fun stuff
that you know makes those movies [ __ ]
really light enjoyable so Captain
America you know they I can't believe I
remember all this from one [ __ ]
viewing Bruce Pat and I'm sure I'm
forgetting something big Bruce Banner
promised the ancient one I will put the
stones back before you know right where
they were I'm gonna return the stones to
each point in time when we take the
stones that way they've never left so
you know technically she's not given up
the time stone for the from the eye of
agamotto like he's gonna return it
before she even gave it up or the
ancient one even gave it a so cap is
tasked with bringing all the stones back
and like well it's gonna take you as
long as you take I was gonna take you
about five seconds in our time you know
you're ready to go you got to make sure
you go back to all the exact places he's
like I'm ready and so they snuck him
through the time hole and [ __ ] they're
like okay bringing him back five four
three two one and he don't come back
through the time hole you know and so
you start sitting there going like
didn't Kat finally take one for himself
and then they see somebody sitting on a
bench a few feet away about a lake and
they walk over and you know I'm sitting
there gone oh my god is it gonna be
young weakling like Steve Rogers before
he got the Super Soldier Serum it's
[ __ ] beautiful it's old Steve Rogers
an old man
it's like 85 90 or something like that
and he's all like wrinkly and he lived a
[ __ ] life and you know he's like I'm
sorry I didn't come come back boys
you know he's like I just I just decided
like I essentially just want to have a
life like after after all that service
after [ __ ] 70 years in the ice after
[ __ ] defeating the Nazis after three
Avengers movies and three [ __ ]
Captain America movies all the [ __ ] this
[ __ ] had to go through he just
wanted a little [ __ ] R&R man he just
wanted a life so he went back and you
know he's wearing a ring and so you see
it at one point and then Falcons talking
to him and he's like do you want to tell
me about her and caps like you know what
No
I don't think I will like he kept
something for himself but cap gives
Falcon the shield and the outfit and
essentially makes Sam the new Captain
America old Captain America old man
Captain America makes Sam Falcon the new
Captain America and [ __ ] and then they
the whole [ __ ] movie ends with a with
a flashback to the past of Steve like a
little house in the middle of nowhere
and they're playing like this you know
old timey 50 song or whatever the [ __ ]
and they push it on the house they push
into the window and there's Steve
dancing with Peggy Carter rips your
[ __ ] heart out like he [ __ ] got
married he got his dream and I was ready
for this [ __ ] to die like they
showed me the trailer looking at that
Peggy picture and Titan in the [ __ ]
shield you're like they're gonna kill
him I can't believe they're showing us
the moment they're gonna kill [ __ ]
Captain America and they didn't these
Marvel [ __ ] are so good at their jobs
they gave Kap a win like he got to
[ __ ] have a life after all that [ __ ]
obviously I'm messy and unfuckable like
you know but that's how I feel about
these movies this movie is spellbinding
ly good I don't think there's ever gonna
be another movie like this you know what
I'm saying I'm like they took 22 movies
to build up to this [ __ ] movie
somebody else could probably try to beat
that somebody else might be able to pull
that off and guess what this ain't the
last [ __ ] Marvel movie they got lots
more probably didn't even the last
Avengers movie but it's the last time
with all these characters that we came
to love over the course of ten years
people that were parts of our family you
know they say that television you know
since it's in our homes and [ __ ] back in
the day when people would turn on a TV
you know it made those people who are on
TV TV stars like part of your family
like Robin Williams when we were working
on Good Will Hunting said like you know
there were people outside the bar we
were shooting that and they were like
Mork and I was like man they still yell
Mork he's like that's what I get the
most and this was decade or more two
decades maybe after Mork and Mindy but
he's I was like really ma'am not good
morning Vietnam he's like TV puts you
into people's homes you're part of their
[ __ ] family
these Avengers they're not a TV show but
they became part of family all these
Marvel movies men we Watchmen thiers we
watch them home relentlessly you know
there's so many of them and there's so
many repeating characters and we've got
to follow their lives and their arcs
that they're deeply entrenched man and
deeply invested there's a reason that
they did those signatures at the end to
kind of mimic what they did with Star
Trek you know the Star Trek credits man
like it is epic something big just
happened here and believe me the media
won't let you forget it it's in all the
news like it's [ __ ] huge but it is
absolutely astounding achievement man so
[ __ ] entertaining beyond satisfying
as I was walking in there's a lot of red
carpet questions like what do you think
is gonna happen I was like I is that
like [ __ ] and so many people asked me
that I was like is that the question
like I never once thought what's gonna
happen that's why I come to this [ __ ] if
I could imagine this [ __ ] I wouldn't
come here I do it for myself and be like
um I don't know Jesus saves them all and
obviously I don't have a lot of
imagination that's why I don't let me
make those [ __ ] movies but I know go
to those movies going here's what I
expect to happen I like to get taken on
a journey and they [ __ ] took me on a
journey three [ __ ] hours all of it
flew by all that [ __ ] short not a
piece of it do I regret I'm not sitting
they're gone they could have done this
they they should have done this this is
all so artfully and beautifully done by
people that love these characters as
much if not more than you and me and
[ __ ] so hats off to the Russo brothers
hats off to Markus and McFeely the
writers hats off to Kevin Feige Victoria
Alonzo all the people who work at the
Marvel Studios and whatnot this is an
incredible [ __ ] achievement this is
not me trying to align myself or
anything like that but the only movie
that I've seen but this much fanservice
treatment is the movie I just finished
making Jay and Silent Bob reboot which
I'm not going to say it's the Avengers
of my movies but I took so much care to
be like oh my god like if you like this
I'm gonna reference this I'm gonna
reference this it's not like deep cuts
where you can't enjoy it but fanservice
because if you're making like a number
two or three or four or five of a movie
they say it about art anymore it's about
fanservice you're giving people what
they want I like those characters a lot
more here you go and hopefully it's
artfully done and they can be standalone
stories but the moment your sequel izing
something you're in the fanservice
business so as always mega Jay and
Silent Bob reboot
I was so meticulous about my fanservice
and I felt proud I'm like nobody's ever
done this before then I saw Avengers
endgame and I was like I'd off my cap to
you sirs you both of you all of you
involved truly understand the meaning of
the term fanservice as well as the
meaning of the term art as well as the
meaning of the term fantastic
storytelling man some people tell me all
the time you like to [ __ ] too much you
like Oh more of a movie you blow
everything [ __ ] whatever I [ __ ] like
what I like and they make great [ __ ] I'm
not alone and then even about a box on a
box office numbers game look at other
people they say the same [ __ ] man I'm in
the bag for this beyond the fact that I
just love good story Tom I don't make
any money off it and [ __ ] in fact I
spend a lot of money on this [ __ ]
because they make these movies I'm like
you know first taste is free and then
after that you got a [ __ ] pay so man
this comes from a fan I love this [ __ ] I
love it to death I've no interest in
making that kind of movie man it seems
too big and time-consuming and takes a
lot of talent that I do not have but
[ __ ] do I like seeing those movies and
I'd love to seeing this I'd watch it
again right now I hope you found this
useful or interesting is that you know
it's a recap of the movie and hopefully
you haven't listened to it until after
you've gotten to see the flick but once
you've done that go sit watch it and see
if I was right what did I forget like
I'm probably sitting here going what the
[ __ ] am I forgetting you know there's
some rocket stuff but like I think I hit
all the major beats I [ __ ] love that
I can't wait to go see it again I'm
gonna say this [ __ ] three four times in
a movie theater arm carrots 3 hours of
peace man I literally could have watched
again right at the end when they rolled
the credits I didn't see any post-credit
scene because we saw it at the premiere
and when the movie ended like all of a
sudden they brought the lights up and
then they brought all the Avengers up on
stage and [ __ ] and they all spoke it was
really [ __ ] beautiful man so I can't
wait to pay to see this a couple times
and see what happens after the credits
roll and stuff like that my hat comes
off to you Marvel I love you thank you
for making movies and make me feel like
I'm a kid again man loved it
Avengers end game 2 stars no I'm kidding
18,000 [ __ ] stars on a scale of four
there you go that's my [ __ ] review
for fat man beyond I'm Kevin Smith man
thanks for hanging out and watching mark
barnard will be along shortly
sure with his review of Avengers endgame
when he gets to see it but there it is
man
swab spoilers
[Music]
you